SPEAKER_00: Cold mattered because rubber does not respond the same way in cold.
SPEAKER_00: A seal that moves quickly when warm can respond more slowly when cold.
SPEAKER_00: In this joint, timing was not a detail.
SPEAKER_00: Timing was the safety margin.
SPEAKER_00: If the seals failed, there was no graceful backup.
SPEAKER_00: Hot gas could burn through the booster casing, reach surrounding structure, and turn a local leak into a vehicle failure.
SPEAKER_00: The o-ring problem had been showing itself before Challenger.
SPEAKER_00: Post-flight inspections found erosion on the primary seal.
SPEAKER_00: In some cases, gas had blown past it and left evidence deeper in the joint.
SPEAKER_00: Engineers documented the damage.
SPEAKER_00: They measured it.
SPEAKER_00: They reported it.
SPEAKER_00: The dangerous part is what happened next.
SPEAKER_00: Because the mission succeeded, because the vehicles came home, damage could be processed as evidence that the system had tolerated the condition.
SPEAKER_00: A damaged component in a surviving system can be read two ways.
SPEAKER_00: One reading says,
SPEAKER_00: We were closer to failure than we should have been, so we stop and fix the condition before we repeat it.
SPEAKER_00: The other says, the vehicle survived, the margin held, and the risk can be carried while improvement work continues.
SPEAKER_00: The second reading became easier each time the shuttle flew and returned.
SPEAKER_00: What had started as a serious anomaly gradually became part of the operating history.
SPEAKER_00: The O-ring warning did not disappear.
SPEAKER_00: It moved.
SPEAKER_00: That is how a warning can die inside a large organization, not through silence, through translation.
SPEAKER_00: It starts when an engineer sees something wrong.
SPEAKER_00: The data is specific.
SPEAKER_00: The language is uncomfortable.
SPEAKER_00: Erosion.
SPEAKER_00: Blow by.
SPEAKER_00: Heat effects.
SPEAKER_00: a seal that did not behave the way the design assumed.
SPEAKER_00: Precise evidence has force.
SPEAKER_00: Then the evidence becomes a discussion item.
SPEAKER_00: It enters a meeting with dozens of other concerns, other anomalies, other systems, other deadlines.
SPEAKER_00: The context broadens, and the urgency flattens.
SPEAKER_00: From there, the discussion becomes a judgment call.
SPEAKER_00: Does this affect the next flight?
SPEAKER_00: The answer depends on the question the room decides to ask.
SPEAKER_00: If the question is, can we prove this will cause a failure?
SPEAKER_00: The answer is usually no.
SPEAKER_00: Predicting a specific loss on a specific flight is hard.
SPEAKER_00: If the question is, can we prove this will not fail?
SPEAKER_00: The answer is also no.
SPEAKER_00: But the first question keeps the schedule alive.